mortgage fee at 740 credit before
1750. now three thousand sixty two
dollars just because you have good
credit 250 bucks a month please you pay
lesser fee for having worse credit bad
credit yes and this is calculated at a
350 000 mortgage twenty percent down
you're paying thirteen hundred dollars
more fee for being responsible with your
credit by the way find us a 350 mortgage
it's more like 600. I don't I don't
normally have high blood pressure just
the opposite but when I saw that cat
this whoa these walk Falls are just
destroying this country they're
destroying economy the political system
the culture the judicial system and
that's why we got to take back Trump's
America that's this 2024 election if we
don't take back the house and the Senate
with Trump Republicans and the White
House this beat will go on it's like uh
they're it just no no so can we play one
game for two minutes sell this to me be
a devil's advocate and sell it
now the common sense makes no sense but
actually
try to make an effort Tom to sell this
or Peter how do you sell this
okay
um
so I'll be I'll be Biden uh what was the
question what are we talking about um
so it's the first thing is I'm going to
help first-time homeowners who are from
lower income because mortgage insurance
and there's a part of this that adds to
your payment so I want to help them but
because it's coming from the federal
side you know we have to have an offset
and the offset is going to be other
people are going to pay more and folks
folks come on now a tax pays for
battleships and for social programs and
a lot of other things and the wealthier
people pay more tax than these people
think of it that way how would you sell
it how do you sell this I'm really
trying to figure out like I'm trying to
well I'm trying to sell it on the
inequitable tax base because that's how
it's been how do you sell this well you
can't sell it because it makes no sense
I mean the reason that I think I found
issue with this it's not exactly to
answer your question but my issue is you
know I've made my name at least in the
social media World about being smart
with your money being prudent with your
money you know being having fiscal
conservative with your money and
paying off debt saving money investing
put it in index funds buying REITs just
driving up your credit score doing
everything you should be doing to have a
good framework for your finances and
then enter this where it's like yeah
turns out we don't need to do any of
that because uh we'll give you a better
loan and if your credit score sucks it's
all good so it it to me it's sort of
just the antithesis of what you're
willing to listen to where you sell
something how do you sell Obamacare okay
you can sell it how do you sell you know
how do you how do you sell this how do
you sell this hey because you are
responsible you got great credit 740
that means you're rich so you can afford
to pay 1300 more to the poor man who is
not responsible with his credit because
that's what we got to do well just a
noble thing to do just because you have
a good credit score doesn't mean you're
rich just means that you're not exactly
drowning in debt and you're paying your
bills on time you're doing what you
should be doing so you can hopefully
become rich I know a lot of broke people
with great credits yeah I know a lot of
great people you know poor people with
credit so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here
[Music]